Did you think your data that was seen by a GPT-3
like model is safely compressed by it? Hidden
among immense amounts of other data?
Then think again.
Is this the end of privacy?
Hm, hm, Ms. Coffee Bean,
did we not forget something?
Let’s say hello first, how about that? Oh, sure!
Hello and welcome to this AI
Coffee Break, where we, we, we...
Where we discuss how it has been possible
by a huge collaboration of big corporate
and university players, to extract training
data from large language models like GPT-2.
Large language models of billions of parameters
are here to stay, just think about BERT, GPT-2
and GPT-3 recently, that made a lot of headlines
[whisper] and made it into a Coffee Break video.
And it is quite common that these (usually
transformer-based) language models
are trained on private datasets.
So this paper is telling us that they developed
an adversary privacy attack that can extract
verbatim training data from their models.
Like names, phone numbers, addresses or
unique identifiers.
Oh no.
In this case, we want to know why
it is possible, how bad this is
and what this would mean
for models other than GPT-2.
But first, a little summary about language models:
A language model is a model that predicts the
next token given the previous ones. The
best example for this is the GPT family.
For generating text with these
models, one has to input some prefix,
which is a sequence of tokens and let the model
predict the next tokens to complete the sequence.
And this is what this paper
does with GPT-2, trained from
public data scraped from the internet.
But bear in mind, the data on the internet
is public, but it is OpenAIs secret which
public data was included in the training set.
This secrecy not wonderful?
Ok, joke aside:
this makes GPT-2 the
perfect test case, because the authors can
attack the model and extract data from it,
and search whether the extracted
data can be found on the internet.
If yes, it was most likely included in
the scraped training set of the model.
But why is it possible to extract
verbatim training instances from
language models in the first place?
Because language models are
memorizing things. If you prompt GPT-2
to complete the sentence “My address
is 1 Main Street, San Francisco CA”,
it generates the correct zip code
for San Francisco, California.
And this kind of memorization is good, especially
with things that have no pattern attached to them,
like unique identifiers, person
names, addresses, phone numbers.
Pattern extraction is what language
models usually do: The majority of the
model’s weights cluster data points that
correspond to a common pattern together.
The spare weights -- if there
are some -- model the outliers,
the unique points with no pattern that are left
out of the cluster and memorized as they are.
And this memorization is good to capture
things like zip codes but become problematic
when things appear only once or twice
during training and get memorized.
For this, the authors define the bad type
of memorization: the k-eidetic memorization.
In simple terms it just means that a string
was k-eidetic memorized if it occurred
k times in the training data and is
extractable from the language model.
Under this definition, it is
ok for the model to memorize
things occurring 1000 of times in the
training data, but bad if k is small.
Now we know that memorization
happens whether we want it or not,
because the model wants to minimize
the loss in the end. So if the model
has enough weights left to model outliers and
pattern-less data points, memorization happens.
So how do the authors exploit this
memorization for developing their
attack? Their pipeline is quite elegant.
They take GPT-2 and generate
200,000 samples of text with GPT-2
conditioned on all sorts of prefixes.
But these generations are not necessarily
memorized pieces of text, they could be anything.
So they sort and select the most
likely pieces to be memorized text.
But the problem here is how to decide
whether the text was memorized or not.
One way to tell is by looking at the
probability of the generated text:
GPT-2 assigns high probability
for memorized strings,
because these data points are outliers,
alone, modelled by their own specific weights.
There is no uncertainty in prediction,
as there is no neighbor data point
that the model can be mislead by.
And to really be certain that
the high confidence of the model
comes from memorization and not from other
regions the model could be certain about,
the authors compare the probability also to
the output of a smaller version of the model,
one that does not have the spare
weights to model these outliers.
Then, these sorted generations are deduplicated,
the top-100 are chosen,
and the evaluation is ready to start,
by searching the generated strings on
the internet to check whether they can
be found verbatim on the world-wide-web.
And how successful is this
adversarial privacy attack?
Well, the situation is worrisome:
for the best variant 67%
of the generated text are word-by-word
repeated snippets from the training data.
Ok, so this was the bad news.
The not that bad news is that
the generated snippets are
not only named individuals,
but also things that are OK,
like licenses or terms of use.
The other thing that is not that bad is: this
adversarial attack can not target specific
names or contact info. It can just generate things
in bulk and Ms. Coffee Bean just needs to hope it
is not about her.
Phew!
Yet another good bad news is, that even
though the paper makes the effort to define
k-eidetic memorization, the tables do not
include the k that much. And when they do,
like in Table 4, it seems like the
k relates to the document count and
not to the number of occurrences
of the string in each document.
So it seems that for strings
to be memorized by GPT-2 XL,
they have to occur more than
30 times in the document.
It is very interesting to see how smaller
versions of GPT-2 need many more string
repetitions to memorize, since they have less
of the spare parameters to model outliers.
But this also means that GPT-3, with
100 times more parameters than GPT-2,
would need far less repetitions
of strings to memorize them.
And here is where the news is really bad
again. Even though this attack that we
have seen is not targeted or tuned
for finding the effective prefixes
from which the language model can
generate the worst memorization,
the paper also shows an example of how much
better a careful tuning of the prompts can be.
When completing a prompt with the first digits
of pi, the first 25 correct digits are completed.
But when prompted with “pi is”,
the model can output 799 digits,
and with this prompt here, it
can output 824 correct digits.
How did the authors even come up with this prompt?
Oh, wow. So what to do about it?
The authors propose training with differential
privacy, where the long tail containing outliers
prone to memorization is removed from training.
They also mention curating the training data…
well, this is hard if not impossible to achieve
with human manpower, since the data is huuuuge.
Fine-tuning may cause the models to forget the
memorization, but might introduce new ones.
Then auditing the models for memorization
seems a good practice and here is
where this paper fits very well.
But it is kind of crazy that it took so long
for a study on these models to come out,
especially since this memorization
issue was known for LSTMs already.
For all the juicy details, read the
paper, linked in the description below.
Do you also like the summary of
contributions at the end of the paper?
Ms. Coffee Bean would love to see this more
often. Let us know in the comments what you think.
Still here? Now go, read the paper.
Or some other paper.
Or anything else you enjoy. Like watching
another Coffee Break video, hiii!
Okay, bye!